- On this episode,
we talk a little education,
we call Denmark, we did good.
(hip hop music)
- [Gary] You ask questions,
and I answer them.
This is The #AskGaryVee Show.
- Hey everybody,
it's Gary Vay-ner-chuk and
this is episode 240
of The #AskGaryVee Show.
Life is good, focused.
Been a very, very
interesting kind of weekend.
A lot going on in the
American political system.
You know, team human
is how I'll always be so
I'll address it right away.
Who's this?
- [Chris] Azeem.
- Azeem, this is GaryVee and
you're on the #AskGaryVee show.
- [Azeem] Oh shit.
What's up Gary?
- What's up man?
Where you from?
- [Azeem] So I'm from
New York, family's from Pakistan.
- Very nice.
- [Azeem] Yeah.
- So you got a question?
- [Azeem] Honestly man, I was
just gonna use this time to say
I'd love to
have coffee with you.
I just want to do
my hustle as you would.
Thought this would be
the best way to do it.
- I think it's a
really good hustle.
I'm not gonna be able to deliver
on that because I'm still 700
internal meetings behind
but I appreciate the hustle.
- [Azeem] Holy shit.
My big thing and
this is for everybody,
I appreciate Azeem
you asking this question.
And by the way, much love and
thanks for watching the show.
- [Azeem] Alright, man.
- Keep doing your thing.
You know, that's devastating.
Everyone's like
whoa what just happened?
I still have 500 internal
meetings that I'm supposed to
have in this company
let alone the outside stuff.
So when I say I can't and
I'm not doing these coffees,
trust me,
I'm devastated that I can't.
My bigger issue is you only have
so many hours in a day between
family, one of the big things I
promised myself in '17 is to do
more internal and less external.
I'm trying to do both.
I'm hustling.
- [Michael] Hello?
- [Chris] Michael.
- Michael, this is GaryVee and
you're on The #AskGaryVee Show.
- [Michael] Yeah, GaryVee a
pleasure to speak with you, sir.
- Thank you, man.
- [Michael] You're a
very busy man.
We actually got to meet on
my 30th birthday
in Austin, Texas.
You were walking
out of your hotel and
I was with my
wife and my daughter.
- Oh man, I remember.
That made DailyVee.
That was on DailyVee,
did you see that?
- [Michael] You
know I never saw it.
I thought to check but I
guess I have to go look at that,
that's cool.
- Well, hold on.
You run into me in the street,
you see DRock is filming.
It's your 30th birthday, we have
this wonderful moment and you
decide not to even just glance
to see if you made the episode?
- [Michael] I'll
have to look at it.
I've been keeping pretty busy.
- I was actually
giving you a compliment.
Much respect,
keep doing your thing.
What's your question brother?
- [Michael] My question is--
- Have your questions ready.
- [Michael] yeah, I'd like to
know a little bit about your
document don't create ethos.
It's something we've been doing
a lot more and I enjoy hearing
your general perspective on it.
- No problem and
I'm glad you're asking.
Thank you so much and I hope
everything's well and it was
really nice to run into you.
- [Michael] Well,
I appreciate that.
- No worries, man.
I'm gonna hang up and
get to the next one but
I love you and stay well.
So documenting versus creating.
Don't dial yet.
This has been a
big breakthrough.
So much so as you guys all
know 'cause you've been watching
DailyVee, some of you.
I really am writing a
new book called Crushed It!
and it's profiling the
people that read Crush It!
and crushed it and giving you
the update on what I would do if
I was a personal brand on
Instagram or Twitter or Snapchat
or how do you build your
personal brand and/or
the business around
your favorite passion.
Be the queen of
strawberries or vegan food or
tailgating or making candles.
That ethos that has played out
even to a greater scale than
most people believed, one that
I believe so much when
I did the first book.
This document instead of
creating thing is so big that
there's been nights and showers
and jam sessions in my own mind
over the last month where I'm
like should I make that book?
Should I quickly sneak in
document and don't create?
Do I make that a big
ethos of Crushed It!?
Here's the punchline, what I am
seeing and so many of you are
answering this is people are
crippled when they have to
create original content but when
you actually understand that you
and your life are the
unique piece of creative,
it changes everything.
Is everybody interesting?
No, I mean the answer is no
not to the macro meaning not
everybody is destined to become
a social media reality star.
But so many people are destined
that will never start
so many people, like look,
you don't have to be
the Kardashians, right?
You can be some version of it.
Here's what I do know.
There are 1,000 people watching
this right now that if they
started making Snapchat stories,
Instagram stories,
YouTube videos, Facebook videos
and post three or four times a
day documenting
what they're doing,
eating this lunch,
taking my kid to school,
this is who my uncle is,
this is my sister,
this is what I'm into,
this is soccer practice.
If they started
documenting instead of ooh,
let me make a video about like
how the sun comes up or instead
of creating something you
just document your actual life.
My biggest belief is so many of
you should be documenting your
journey of becoming an intern,
of becoming, moving from college
to the real life,
going through your divorce,
starting your new business.
If you document your truth my
belief is that there is stunning
amount 1,000 of you watching
right now who could make as much
money and that might be $80,000,
that might be $380,000.
You could make as much money
documenting your life through
all these channels and
making monetization through ads,
affiliates, sponsorship deals,
speaking engagements,
books and all the other
ancillary things that happen.
You could make as
much money being you.
As much money being Tyler Babin
as getting paid at VaynerMedia
being Tyler Babin
in the production team.
Like I just believe that truth.
Now that might not
be for everybody but
it is for a lot of you.
And unlike Tyler Babin,
thank God,
most of you don't like your job.
He likes it.
So that's what would prevent him
and you may love your job and
that will prevent you.
But if you are sitting here
today in 2017 and you are
watching this piece of content
which means you listen to my
themes and care about my stuff
and you're in this ethos.
You can start dialing, well
then you need to understand what
documenting versus creating is.
Not everybody's
gonna create that show.
You know, it's a lot easier to
make a documentary than "Cheers"
if you understand the power of
the current platforms
and things of that nature.
It's not that documenting is
so easy either but just telling
your real life on a daily basis
super interesting to me and
something all of
you should at least try.
What's the cost?
A couple leisure
hours on bullshit?
- [Tarek] Hello, this is Tarek.
- Derrick or what?
- [Chris] Tarek.
- Tarek.
- [Tarek] Tarek.
- It's GaryVee and
you're on the show.
- [Tarek] No fucking way.
- Yes, bro.
- [Tarek] Are you kidding me?
- I'm not kidding.
I'm fucking
real as shit on this.
You're on the show.
- [Tarek] I'm dying right now.
- Where you from?
- [Tarek] My heart is pounding.
- I love it.
- [Tarek] Oh, I love you Gary.
I love you so much.
You have no idea.
- I love you back, bro.
Where you from?
- [Tarek] I'm from Denmark.
- Love it.
- [Tarek] I can't believe you
called all the way to Denmark.
- Yeah, we're going
international on this show.
We finally figured out
how to use this thing and call
international so we're gonna go
international heavy for a little
while now, catch up.
So what's your question, bro?
- [Tarek] Amazing.
Thank you so much
for the love, man.
You shout me out on
Instagram not so long ago.
- Yep.
- [Tarek] Amazing.
Sorry, I'm get to the question.
- Please.
- [Tarek] So, ugh,
so nervous right now.
(DRock laughs)
Okay, because of you
I have decided to go all-in
on an idea I had and go to L.A.
start out with my friends.
And ever since,
just give me a sec.
- No worries.
- [Tarek] I'm so
nervous right now.
- No worries.
Do your thing.
It's just me and you here.
- [Tarek] I fucking love you.
- I love you back, brother.
Let's do this.
So you go to L.A.
with your friends.
Have you gone to
L.A. yet or not yet?
Not yet obviously,
we just called Denmark.
- [Tarek] I was actually in L.A.
and tried to meet you.
I went to your office because
I wanted to meet you so bad.
- (laughs) Was I there?
- [Tarek] You weren't there.
You were in L.A. I was kind of
stalking you on Snapchat.
- No problem.
- [Tarek] Trying to
figure out where you were.
But you weren't there.
I'm positive we've
got to meet some day.
- I'm sure of it.
- [Tarek] Anyways,--
- Let's get to this question
'cause if you don't ask this
question in the next 5 seconds,
you're gonna be off the show and
I will never meet you.
- [Tarek] Oh my God.
Alright, so I'm from Denmark.
I'm not an American citizen.
- Yes.
- [Tarek] I want to go and start
up this company in the U.S.
- Yes.
- [Tarek] It's difficult.
My partner is from the U.S.
- Yes.
- [Tarek] What we're trying
to do is a new social media
platform that's in
fitness and health.
And one of the most important
things for us right now is
trying to make a
minimum viable product.
But I feel like we're stuck.
What can I do to make
this happen?
We have the strategy in place.
We have a business plan.
- What's the strategy?
Fuck a business plan.
- [Tarek] Well,--
- Your strategy is to make
a fitness social network, right?
- [Tarek] Yeah,
a social media platform
within fitness and health.
- Right. That's not a strategy.
That's a thesis.
If you had a strategy, you'd
be executing against it and
you wouldn't be
asking me this question.
So that's an important--
- [Tarek] We're trying
to speak with influencers.
- Everybody's trying to do that.
- [Tarek] Exactly, we want
to have them on board
to have some leverage.
- What are you offering them?
- [Tarek] We go
and, we need to go and
speak with investors, right?
- What are offering them?
- [Tarek] What we're trying
to do is this platform--
- No, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no.
What are you offering
influencers that you're trying
to siphon attention out of their
world and want to steal their
attention and take it
for yourself selfishly,
what are you offering
them to be a part of this?
- [Tarek] We're
trying to offer them like,
oh my God this is so difficult
to explain in such a short time.
We're trying to offer them
to have a whole new platform,
take advantage of
their brands--
- And what, they're gonna
monetize of your platform better
than they're
monetizing off Instagram?
- [Tarek] Exactly.
They'll be able to market
a whole new target group.
In terms of a lot of
the influencers--
- Why? You have no users.
Instagram has hundreds
of millions of people on it.
- [Tarek] Yeah, exactly.
We're not trying to take
anything away from Instagram.
We're just trying to offer them
new opportunities to monetize
their personal brands.
- Tarek, every single person is
trying to build a platform for
influencers to monetize their
brands in other places and so
what you're trying to do is
build a platform that shares the
economics of influencers that
actually have users and you just
want to do that by painting a
picture that they'll make more
than they will on Instagram when
Instagram actually gives them
the attention, the eyeballs that
they're actually
monetizing off of.
- [Tarek] Oh, this is
hard for me to explain, Gary.
I'm sorry that I
don't have a more--
- No worries, brother.
This was a good
starting point,
no, no, listen.
Feel free to send me an email,
I'll try to read it if I get a
chance but here's
what I promise you.
Everybody's trying to take from
influencers instead of give them
and when you say we'll
give them better monetization
opportunities, it's just not
true if you have no audience.
You know that right?
- [Tarek] Yeah.
- If you have no audience--
- [Tarek] We're trying to give
them a way better opportunity to
talk with their audience as well
and make sure that the content
that they're creating is not,
it will be much more detailed.
Yeah, I can't explain this.
- What I can tell you, no
you're doing everything fine.
Let me tell you one thing
that everybody gets wrong.
If you don't have people, if you
don't have people to give the
influencers and you want them
to come on so they bring their
audience, you've lost.
- [Tarek] Mhmmm.
- You've lost.
- Unless you're giving
them meaningful equity in your
company, you've lost.
Everybody, it's a
chicken and egg game, Tarek.
You know, everybody wants, you
want influencers 'cause you want
them to bring the million people
that pay attention to them over
and sign up for your world.
No matter how much economics you
give them you're getting more
than you're giving them in that
first move which means you'll
never get started.
You have to solve for that.
That's a strategy.
- [Tarek] Yeah.
- How do you
bring them more value?
- [Tarek] This is about
the actual users themselves.
We're trying to get influencers
on board to have leverage when
we want to talk to so people,
some investors like yourself
Gary so that maybe the question
is like what do you think is the
best strategy--
- I think the best strategy
is not to be in a place--
- [Tarek] for a person like me?
- To build something
without being at the
mercy of raising money.
Everybody wants to raise money.
By the way, if you walked in
here with 15 fitness supermodels
that made my tongue hit the
ground and they had 40 million
fucking followers, I still have
no interest investing in your
fucking company.
Don't think that influencers on
board are gonna get you money.
The market's very,
very, very tight right now.
There's a lot of
uncertainty in the U.S. market.
VCs are not throwing around
money because you got a couple
of cute chicks and
guys with six-packs and
a couple million followers.
- [Tarek] Exactly,
okay, got you.
- Good. Alright,
I'll talk to you soon.
- [Tarek] Thank you so much.
- The way you need to actually
execute on something that shows
me traction not theory.
You're in theory mode.
You have to do.
- [Tarek] Uh-huh.
- The best companies
did and then raised money.
Now we're in a generation where
everybody wants money first.
Make something, make an
MVP that actually works.
How do you do that?
Work a fucking side job and
use the money for that to do it.
Everybody thinks that money's an
entitlement up front any more.
Nobody's giving
you fucking money.
- [Tarek] Got you.
- Good.
- [Tarek] Thank you
so much, Gary.
- You're welcome.
And this is it.
Go ahead.
And this is it, guys and girls.
We're in this modern era and now
everybody thinks like his whole
strategy was I'm gonna
take influencers who have big
audiences, I'm gonna slap that
as they're a part of my thing
and that's gonna get
VCs to be excited about it.
It's not enough for
VCs to be excited about.
First of all there's
a million influencers.
They're unlimited,
they're commoditized.
Second of all, you can't
even explain your product.
Where are you going?
And everybody's trying to
steal from these influencers.
Everybody's got the same
fucking bullshit strategy.
I get hit up a
million times a day,
I'm gonna help
you monetize more.
I can monetize my-fucking-self.
Dunk figured out
how to monetize himself.
(phone ringing) Fucking help me.
No, you want my shit.
And then we can
monetize together, fuck you.
Give me half your house and then
we can sell it and make money.
I've got the
fucking house, bitch.
Get somebody else. You know?
The reason so many of you are
losing is because your model is
predicated on somebody
giving you more value up front.
You're not offering anything.
If he answered me precisely and
said well I'm giving 5% of my
company to five different people
now you have a conversation.
You DM @Dunk and say I'm gonna
give you 11% of this sneaker
business, now all of a
sudden maybe he'll look at it.
Not, hey give me a shout out for
my sneaker business because on
my platform more
people will pay attention.
He's got 2 million
fans on his platform.
You got shit, dick.
You got nothing.
You need me first.
You got an empty club.
You need me to
bring the bitches. Got it?
- [Shoez] Hello?
- What?
Hello, who's this?
- [Shoez] Hello.
- [Chris] DJ Shoez.
- DJ Shoez it's GaryVee, you're
on the The #AskGaryVee Show.
- [Shoez] What's that?
- This is Gary Vaynerchuk.
Did you put your number on
Twitter to be
on my call-in show?
- [Shoez] Yeah, I did.
- Great. Well, you're on it.
- [Shoez] No, whoa,
get the fuck out. No way.
- Yes, man.
This is me.
My name is Gary Vaynerchuk.
Gary V-E-E on Twitter.
You put your phone number,
I do a show, it's episode 240,
you're on it. What up?
- [Shoez] Oh my God.
Oh my God.
Good to meet you Gary.
You've been a big part
of my drive and my life.
Can't believe
I'm talking to you.
- I appreciate it, man.
What's your question?
- [Shoez] Well I'll
ask you my question,
first, (inaudible) I'm
gonna give you some back up
(inaudible).
- I'm sorry, I couldn't
hear that very clearly.
- [Shoez] I'm sorry. I said I'm
gonna ask you a question but
I'm gonna give you some of my
backup to the question as well.
- Okay.
- [Shoez] So
it'll make more sense.
- Go ahead.
Fire away.
- [Shoez] Great.
So the question itself is
if I were your client
at VaynerTalent what would
your next move for me be?
- Meaning, yep.
- [Shoez] (inaudible)
- I can hear you clearly.
If you're paying me $30,000
and now you're a
client of VaynerTalent.
You're pay me $30,000 a month,
the first thing
that would happen is
we would sit down with you and
ask you what the hell do you
want to accomplish. Right?
Do you want to get a lot more
notoriety so you can album?
Do you want to have a book deal?
Do you want to create
your own social media agency?
Do you want to sell sneakers?
Do you want to get paid
$15,000 a night to spin?
Like we always go
backwards from the North Star.
I want to buy the
New York Jets so everything
I do ladders up to that.
Got it?
- [Shoez] Right.
So that's exactly the thing,
I know exactly what I want.
- What do you want?
- [Shoez] So here's
where I'm at is,
I want to tour.
I want to tour and
have a local fan base,
a loyal fan base, that
let's me do what I love to do.
- I love it.
- [Shoez] Which is
produce music and DJ.
- Love it.
- [Shoez] Here's my situation.
(inaudible) I'm currently
stationed over in Italy but my
thing is is two
and a half years ago
I started to go
all-in with this.
(mumbles) this is it.
It clicked for me.
There's nothing that
would make me happier.
So I went all-in.
I started listening
to you and I started
(phone cutting in and out).
Instagram ads.
Sending all my merch
out to influencers
people all around.
- Yep.
- [Shoez] Trying to
get my name out there.
- Yep. Keep going.
- [Shoez] Every time I'm not
working I'm in the studio,
I'm making music, so my big plan
is right now I'm trying to
build brand awareness.
- Yes. That's right.
That's right so keep going.
- [Shoez] However, in about nine
months I'm going back to the
States and my plan the is to
go get my (inaudible) big major
clubs that I know out there,
offer my services for six months
to a year for free.
DJ there for free.
Get some value from that club
and after that ask if they will
hire me on as a full-time DJ.
- I love it.
Are you gonna be
able to, it's great.
That's exact, I love it.
I love your strategy.
Are you gonna be able to afford
to work for free for six or
nine months when you come
back to the States from Italy?
- [Shoez] Yeah, absolutely.
I'll have three years until
my contract runs out.
That's how my plan.
By the time the contract is out,
I have something--
- So let's--
- [Shoez] After
that what's my move?
How do I get to start
touring? How do I get that?
- Well once, look this
is a very basic question.
Once you get enough people
to give a shit about you
venues will book you left and
right and you can tour forever.
I mean this is not complicated.
You look at Russ
the rapper in Atlanta,
puts out a song every week,
does it for
four years, whatever.
Eventually a couple songs pop.
He gets a little thing then he
has one song go completely pop
crazy and now
he's touring every day
selling out
shows left and right.
I mean this is a business model,
you don't need the GaryVee show
to understand this.
You need to put out music every
day or as close as you can get.
Here's the model.
You start at the
moon and you go backwards.
You should put out
music every single day.
Now, you're gonna say
well listen I'm stationed here.
I can't do that.
I can't do this.
Great.
Is it 364 days that
you can put out music?
Great, you can't.
Is it 360 days of music?
Oh, you can't?
Okay, is it 290 days of music?
You need to put out music every
day on Soundcloud and Spotify
and then you need to make as
much content on social media
networks to bring awareness.
You need to follow hashtags, you
need to DM people on Instagram.
All the moves that
I've been talking about.
The real answer to your question
is it actually has to work.
Meaning like you
have to have the talent.
There's no model,
there's no way to
become prettier except for
plastic surgery and
so then you're dealing
with what you're dealing with.
Like you just might
not be good enough to tour
at the level you aspire to be.
I don't know but I can tell you
the best way to find out is to
put out music every day.
- [Shoez] Got it.
Absolutely, Gary.
- Like there's no
secret sauce here.
It's putting out content where
people actually are as often as
you humanly can. The end.
That is the strategy.
For all of you.
- [Shoez] Alright, Gary.
- Alright? Alright, man.
I mean that's it.
Like everybody's
looking for some sort of hack.
Here's the hack.
Whatever you're producing put
out that product to where it is,
you're selling something you
put it on Amazon Marketplace,
eBay, start your
own store, Shopify,
like put it out.
Put out creative.
Marketing, videos,
pictures on all the platforms
we all spend our time on.
Instagram, Snapchat,
Twitter, Facebook,
YouTube and just do it as often
as you possibly can and then
you'll find out whether
the world likes it or not.
It's literally
that fucking basic.
Here's the problem, you
guys don't want to do that.
- [Eliot] (inaudible)
amplify the relationships
just like we talked about.
- [Gary] 100%.
What's going on here?
That's a whole lot of practice.
I don't, but it's great that
that didn't work 'cause I can
drill it home one more time.
What do you want from me?
There's no cheat code.
There's no up,
up, down, down, left,
right, left right, B,
A, B, A, select start.
Not in this game.
You got to put out the content.
You got to put out
as often as you can.
You got to let
the market decide.
But you have to be
smart about where and how.
Don't make a CD and
shop it to A&amp;R people.
Put the fucking music
on Spotify and Soundcloud.
That's how you get
discovered. But you might suck.
Hello, it's GaryVee.
You're on The #AskGaryVee Show.
- [Julie] Gary, my favorite
corporate thug motivator.
- [Chris] Julie.
- Julie, how you doin'?
- [Julie] I'm good.
How are you?
- I'm super well.
What can I answer for you?
- [Julie] Gary, I just
want to say thank you,
thank you, thank you
for everything first of all.
- Thank you Julie.
- [Julie] You are the best.
And what you can
answer for me is
let's talk about
high school education.
- Okay.
- [Julie] What are the top
two things that you think could
change in public education right
now for students that are bored
to death in school?
- So help me.
I want to, I can
talk about things in
general terms all the time.
Having a Q&amp;A show allows me to
be a little bit more specific to
the person calling and I want to
really deliver for you so help
me understand this.
You're asking from
what perspective?
- [Julie] I'm asking
from an educational,
from a federal educational
perspective versus what is
really happening in high school.
How far behind we
are in education--
- What are you in this?
Are you talking about a child?
Are you an educator?
Why do you care about this and
what do you do that
ties into this discussion?
- [Julie] I'm an educator.
I actually work
in public education.
- Love it. As a?
- [Julie] I work
at a high school.
I'm with 1700 students a day
that are basically not allowed
to use their cell phones.
- Right.
And you play what
role in that world?
- [Julie] I'm actually a
teacher and a department chair.
- Love it.
Okay, so here's what I think and
I think it's amazing to have you
on the call here and
we can go back and forth.
I think if you're calling me and
you've heard some of my spiel
then you are an amazing teacher
to these kids because you are
not blindly following the
playbook that has been pushed
down our throats on this issue.
Which is you know as well as I
do when you really look at the
curriculum of the average public
high school in America today
it's not the most--
- [Julie] Oh, it's terrible.
- (laughs) It's
just not practical.
So here's what I would say.
The number one thing
that I think you can do,
and I'm not kidding,
is the following.
One by one, one by one, in the
same way that I do it on social
and in life, one by one when
you see these kids whether it's
their parents when they're
picking them up or at a sporting
event or when you have a
scheduled meeting or when you
see them you have
to break the ethos
and have that one on
one conversation.
You need to grab Gary Vaynerchuk
in your class who's a sophomore,
right, and you
need to pull him aside.
- [Julie] Right. I
got several little Garys.
- Good.
- [Julie] I've
got sneaker heads.
I've got hip hop music kids.
- Let's not get crazy
that they're Garys.
The might be mini.
- [Julie] Math, science.
- So, listen.
You need to grab them aside and
you need to give them the wink.
Your wink may
change their life forever.
You encouraging these
kids with saying I see you,
I understand.
Now I can't tell you what to
appease your parents with.
Maybe they want you
to get this diploma,
maybe not, duh-duh-duh-duh
but I'm telling you my friend,
more than anything in
the world Mrs. Kennedy,
Señora Kennedy is the only
teacher I had in high school
that gave me the wink.
Her wink came by her
calling my mother and saying,
"Mrs. Vaynerchuk,
"Gary's gonna get a
D in Spanish this year.
"I don't think he knows how to
say hola but I know that your
"son is gonna win in life and
I know that he needs to pass
"Spanish to
graduate high school."
She gave me the wink.
I'm telling you
right now I'm 41 years old.
This wink happened
when I was 17, right?
Please,--
- [Julie] Right.
- you're not gonna
change the macro thing.
You know what's going on.
- [Julie] I know
what's going on,
it's not right.
- Correct.
So what I want you
to do is be practical.
You're not gonna
change the whole system.
I'm not gonna make a
video that goes viral and
changes the whole system.
The head of education now in
this country has her objectives.
It's gonna be very
different than what we've seen.
I have no idea where it goes.
I'm not the kind of person that
thinks all politics to the left
or right are
all bad or all good.
I have no idea,
I do it one by one,
but here's what I can tell you.
You, darling, for calling me and
asking me this question you need
to go overboard with those
little Garys in your class and
you need to give them the wink.
Which is listen to me
Charles, listen to me Susan.
I see you.
I see what you're passion about
and selling shit is always gonna
allow you to be successful in
life so keep tripling down.
Don't, you know, don't get me
in trouble with your parents,
like I'm not telling you
to drop out of high school.
But somebody giving them
a wink and saying I see you,
believe it or not,
you doing that,
and don't force it.
Don't bullshit it.
Don't just do it--
- [Julie] Nope, the
kids know the bullshit.
They see right through it.
- So I'm telling
you in reverse they see
right through it the other way.
You go grab Ricky out of class
and bring him into your office,
especially if you make
it impactful like that.
He's in science class but
somehow you pull him out for
impact and you
sit him down and say,
"Ricky, listen to me.
You're gonna fuckin' win.
"I see it.
I watch your hustle.
"I see your charisma.
"I see your drive
and I know it's not to do
"well on a Scantron
test tonight.
"I see what you're doing and
I want you to know that I,
"I see it and if I could
ever be a help to you,
"I got you and
remember that I see it.
"In a world where a lot of other
people are just gonna go by the
"book, I see what you've got and
I'm here for you and
"I'm proud of you."
We need way more encouragement.
They're playing in an ecosystem
that isn't practical and then
most of the teachers are just
playing by the book and they're
discouraging so
real life encouragement,
around real truths is the
number one thing you could do.
It's the cliche shit, Jules.
Help four kids and
you're helping as much
as you can actually do.
Do you understand?
- [Julie] I understand, Gary.
- Do it aggressively.
- [Julie] I appreciate you, man.
- I appreciate you.
- [Julie] I love you.
- I love you back,
thank you. I love this, man.
Perfectly parented,
it's coming out.
I know I got to go.
Nope, that's it.
Question of the day:
Who's the last person
that you positively impacted?
You keep asking questions,
I'll keep answering them.
(hip hop music)